aimant les manifestations dépit de
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes se sont multipliés
ces derniers jours dans le sillage de la
sphère floride aux états unis le
personnel soignant lui en france appelle
à plusieurs journées de mobilisation
alors question y at il un deux poids
deux mesures dans le traitement des
manifestations dont certaines sont
tolérés d'autres noms c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes en direct avec atom
apporte un dirigeant national du pcf en
charge du collectif des cheminots auteur
de au coeur de laine aux éditions
arcane17 bonsoir thomas porte merci
d'être avec nous pour en débattre avec
vous julien ondulent conseiller régional
rassemblement national bonsoir à vous
également julien odoul alors il n'y aura
pas de sanction contre les participants
les manifestations sont interdites mais
tolérée c'était les mots de christophe
castaner hier à quelques heures
justement avant ces rassemblements en
mémoire à giorgio foid contre les
violences policières et contre le
racisme
julien aux boules quelle a été votre
réaction à cette tolérance entre
guillemets du ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai été scandalisé par cette annonce de
christophe castaner puisque je me
rappelle qu'il ya dix huit mois les
manifestations des gilets jaunes et t
elle même durement réprimé avec une
brutalité politiques extrêmes
elle n'était pas elle était interdite et
elles étaient réprimées là nous avons
des manifestations dont on nous dit
qu'elles sont interdites mais qu'elles
sont finalement toléré et qu'elles sont
tolérés sous le prétexte totalement
délirant que c'est l'émotion mondiale
que c'est la mort de georges floyd et
donc ça autorise tout et ça permet
finalement de bafouer l'état de droit ça
permet de passer outre les consignes
sanitaires je rappelle quand même que
nous venons de traverser une crise
sanitaire sans précédent que nous avons
près de 30000 morts dans notre pays que
nous ne sommes pas encore sortis et que
ces consignes sont extrêmement
importantes donc l'émotion
moi j'aurais aimé qu'elle soit aussi
les gilet jaune puisque les idées jaune
c'était aussi l'émotion de gens qui
venaient crier leur ras-le-bol face à un
matraquage fiscal face à des conditions
de j abominable face à un état qui ne
les écoute pas face à des personnes
aujourd'hui dans notre pays qui ne
peuvent pas se soigner qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim
moi j'aurais aimé aussi qu'on écoute
cette émotion là on constate que le
gouvernement et le maquereau finalement
c'est de la discrimination
discrimination à l'égard des castes
populaire à l'égard des manifestants des
gilet jaune
mais pour ce qui est des militants
racialiste pour ce qui est des partisans
de monsieur adama sall ya aucun problème
les manifestations seront tolérés c'est
un véritable scandale qui en dit long
sur l'abaissement de l'état de notre
pays thomas par 3,3 rex je crois que moi
je suis pas là pour opposer les
mobilisations
j'ai été aussi le premier à dénoncer les
violences policières l'entente étaient
victimes les légers les jeunes je crois
que le pouvoir que la bonne décision en
tolérant ces mobilisations j'espère
qu'il va faire de même avec les
soignants et aujourd'hui c'est
absolument pas des mobilisations
racialiste cd mobilisation qui
s'inscrivent dans une exigence de
justice et de transparence
elles répondent aux mêmes idéaux que
toutes les mobilisations sociales qui
est dans le pays depuis des semaines
c'est à dire plus de services publics
plus d'égalité et aujourd'hui c'est ça
ce qu'on dénonce ce que dénonce et
mobilisation c'est une police qui
aujourd'hui se permet d'avoir une
violence extrêmement importante à la
fois les gardes et gilet jaune mais
aussi dans les quartiers populaires les
chiffres le disent il ya un dernier
sondage qui a été dans le chic tombe
parce qu'il dit que un tiers des
français se sent aujourd'hui en ag face
à la police donc il faudra répondre à
ces questions là et le gouvernement n'y
réponds pas aujourd'hui et les
mobilisations elles vont continuer tant
que vous pouvez
là vous vous répondez sur le fond
démobilisation mais c'est bien tout
l'objet de ce débat est ce que
christophe castaner à raison justement
d'opposer
les raisons ces mobilisations est-ce que
c'est plus important voilà d'aller
manifester pour le contre le racisme
contre les voilà les problèmes à
l'hôpital où c'est ça le sujet de fond
finalement est ce que un ministre a
raison de tolérer au nom de l'émotion
ces rassemblements alors qu'on le
rappelle tout de même que les
rassemblements sont interdits de plus de
10 personnes aujourd'hui dans le pays on
empêche par exemple des familles
d'enterrer leurs proches correctement
c'est ça le sujet aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de classification à faire
sur les mobilisations qu'elle soit
contre les violences policières contre
le climat ou pour affaire risque de la
santé elles sont toutes légitimes elles
ont toutes des revendications concrètes
qui doivent permettre de s'exprimer
maintenant je vois que monsieur odoul
s'insurge sur le fait que les jmj ont
été réprimées je n'ai pas entendu monté
au créneau quand le 1er mai 2019 la cgt
a été violentée par les forces de
l'ordre et on a dû exfiltrer le
secrétaire général de la cgt philippe
martinez donc voilà il ya aussi un deux
poids deux mesures moi je considère que
la répression policière des
manifestations ne doit jamais exercé
dans le cadre de mobilisations sociales
qui sont pacifiques
on le voit les mobilisations contre les
violences policières en memorial des
fouilles
elle se passe très bien il n'y a pas de
débordements et c'est une idiotie
elles sont pacifiques et la question
quand je voyais des slogans quand vous
voyez des pancartes mort au port comme
vous voyez qu on entonne des chants
appelant à prendre les armes contre nos
policiers c'est tout sauf pacifique
vous appelez à la haine de la france
vous appeler à la haine de nos policiers
vous appeler à la guerre raciale c'est
tout ce que je ne veux pas pour mon pays
parce que moi contrairement à vous
monsieur porte mon pays je ne le vois
pas en fonction de couleurs si ce n'est
trois le bleu le blanc et le rouge
moi je ne vois pas les individus en
fonction de leur origine moi je vois des
français et citoyen français et la
guerre raciale qui donc que nous ne
voulons pas que ces racialiste j'irai
appellent de leurs voeux par ces
manifestations en essayant de cliver en
essayant de renvoyer un policier donc
dans le rang des vendus c'est totalement
d'une part c'est totalement innommable
et d'autre part c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux pour la france dans laquelle
nous voulons vivre demain
donc il faut y mettre un terme moi ce
que j'entends et ce que je vois ce n'a
rien de pacifique
ce serait bien que le ministre de
l'intérieur que le gouvernement dise une
bonne fois pour toutes stop
ces manifestations elles sont interdites
elles sont interdites d'une part parce
qu'à l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
d'autre part parce qu'elles appellent à
la haine raciale
je crois qu'elle n'appelle pas du tout à
la haine raciale et vous vous ne trouvez
pas là pour défendre les slogans qui
s'en vont prononcer elle porte une
exigence celle de la transparence sur la
question des violences policières et
vous voulez l'évacuer et tous les
chiffres le disent
l'augmentation dès violences policières
et là on a aujourd'hui une police qui a
tué des personnes et adama traoré année
1k et d'ailleurs vous avez dit aux gens
que vous avez dit vous avez dit hier que
adama 3 y avaient été tués parce que
c'était un délinquant et que rien
imposer le fait qu'ils restent sur douze
quand vous avez été mis en examen pour
recel de détournement d'argent public
la police n'est pas venu chez vous elle
n'est pas venue vous agresser le support
monsieur port du fait des amalgames qui
soulevait pas de morale ayant monté ça
n'a rien à voir
je sais que celle d'une petite cuisine
habituelle mais un moment donné il faut
revoir qu'est ce que la normalité de
notre pays qu'est ce que nous voulons
pour notre société
est ce que nous voulons une société de
paix et de sécurité la paix et la
sécurité malheureusement dans toute
société humaine
elle est garantie par la violence
légitime exercée par les forces de
l'ordre par la police répliquant et la
police républicaine rempli sa mission
je dirais en france la police qu'on veut
républicaine rempli sa mission avec
professionnalisme avec le souci des
personnes la sécurité des personnes avec
le souci du respect de la loi
ça c'est la police française et c'est
pas les caricatures qu'on entente
alors évidemment que comme dans tous les
corps de la société comme dans tous les
métiers il peut y avoir des brebis
galeuses il peut y avoir des individus
qui peuvent déplorer pu y avoir des
individus qui sont moins bien formés
mais jeter le discrédit de cette façon
sur toute une institution qui est
essentiel pour notre vivre en paix en
france alors je trouve ça ancien dicton
jours voulez vous faire réagir sur cette
autre déclaration de christophe castaner
qui a beaucoup fait parler de lui
manifestement ces derniers jours le
ministre de l'intérieur qui était invité
d'une matinale info d'une grande chaîne
interrogée sur l'interdiction de la
manif des soignants prévue mardi
prochain à cause des règles de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire voici sa réponse
il faut que les manifestations soient
déclarés il est important aussi de
rappeler le droit mais surtout les
conditions sanitaires
les personnels soignants le savent mieux
que d'autres
une manifestation aujourd'hui c'est
prendre le risque de diffuser le virus
thomas porte ça vous inspire quoi ça
c'est dangereux de manifester avant
c'était dangereux à cause des black
blocs là c'est le virus est ce que selon
vous voilà il ya une arrière pensée de
la part du gouvernement qui voudrait
décourager les gens à manifester dans ce
pays aujourd'hui
évidemment qu'une tentative de mettre
fin aux mobilisations sociales quelle
qu'elle soit on a connu la récession
avant le gros navires us et on sait
qu'on aura une répression après puisque
tout ce qui tend à remettre en cause
aujourd'hui le maquereau nisme va être
montré du doigt par ce coureur et le
secteur de la santé peut être celui qui
coagule les colères populaires parce
qu'on avait un compris dans ce pays
qu'on avait besoin d'un grand service
public de la santé qui permettent à
toutes et tous de se soigner
correctement et cette crise là elle a
mis en avant les décisions politiques
qui ont été pris depuis des années qui
ont détruit ce service public et la
majorité la très grande majorité des
gens ont compris qu'il fallait sortir
des logiques de rentabilité qu'un
hôpital n'est pas un tableur excel est
aujourd'hui s'il ya bien un secteur qui
en pointe qui était en lutte depuis un
an que le gouvernement n'avait pas
écouté les soignants été complice des
violences qui était énorme
il ne les a pas écoutés il les a
applaudis et aujourd'hui veulent leur
interdire à nouveau de manifester leur
colère
je crois que c'est pas très sérieux mais
christophe castaner et toute sa famille
de l'intérieur puisque les décisions
sont d'une incohérence totale
les prises de position répondent aux
intérêts du jour il n'y a pas de ligne
de conduite on espère vraiment que les
soignants vont être nombreux à se
mobiliser j'espère aussi que la
population qui les a applaudi pendant
des semaines et des mois va être à leurs
côtés pour exiger aujourd'hui d'avoir un
service public hospitalier de digne avec
des conditions de travail décentes et
une hausse des salaires qui permet à
toutes et tous de se soigner dans ce
pays donc manifestation soignants prévue
demain comme tous les jeudis une grosse
le 16 juin et ce qu'on doit l'autoriser
puisque on vous prévient que ça va être
quand même dangereux oui je suis tout à
fait en accord une fois n'est pas
coutume avec ce qu'il vient de dire
thomas porte notamment sur le sauvetage
de l'hôpital public et de notre système
de santé
ce qui est hallucinant dans les propos
de christophe castaner c'est
véritablement ce deux poids deux mesures
pourquoi les personnels soignants donc
seraient plus susceptibles de propager
le virus et non pas les militants
racialiste pourquoi ceux qui veulent
sauver l'hôpital public donc devrait
s'astreindre aux règles sanitaires et
non pas ceux qui défilent pour georges
floyd un moment donné la règle la loi et
doit être la même pour tous voilà sinon
il ya plus de république
sinon il ya plus de démocratie je dirais
sinon c'est l'anarchie et tout ça nous
ne pouvons pas l'accepter
donc oui j'espère que les personnels
soignants vont se mobiliser nombreux
parce que leur combat est légitime parce
que ça fait des années qu'ils tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé parce que nous avons
un système de santé qui s'étire man 10
et qui a été il a mis en coupe réglée
par ce gouvernement
donc ils ne voient que la rentabilité à
outrance et qui n'a pas tiré visiblement
les leçons de ces semaines de crise
donc oui j'espère qu'ils vont se
mobiliser et oui j'espère aussi
connaissent de l'intérieur va arrêter de
faire sont deux poids deux mesures ces
discriminations et une bonne fois pour
toutes
arrêtez d'être le ministre du désordre
les désordres et de la confrontation à
un moment donné ça suffit
notre pays on a trop souffert donc la
règle la loi doit être la même pour tous
en france
merci je n'ai redoublent merci également
à vous ou thomas porte d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france pour ce
débat